welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Jason Lyle assistant professor of
political science at Yale University his
research focuses on the dynamics of
violence in both conventional and
guerilla warfare with special emphasis
on Afghanistan and Russia's Northern
Caucasus particularly Chechnya professor
Lyles work draws on diverse methods
ranging from historical and cross
national comparisons to field and quasi
experiments at the sub-national and
local level his research has been
published in the American Political
Science Review International
Organization Journal of conflict
resolution and world politics today
we'll speak with him about his article
that's forthcoming in the American
political science review titled our Co
ethnics more effective counter
insurgents evidence from the second
chechen war
welcome professor Lyle thank you your
paper looks at whether or not ethnicity
matters in looking at violence during
civil wars give us an overview of your
paper absolutely yes the broad central
question in this really does ethnicity
matter for explaining patterns of
violence and civil wars and what we're
really interested in here is explaining
how insurgents attack where they attack
whom they attack the spatial
distribution of that the patterns over
time and the second chechen war allows
us to get a window into that particular
process because the patterns have been
so dynamic so varied across time and so
what I've done with this particular
paper is which is part of a larger
project looking at the whole Northern
Caucasus is to look at patterns of
violence since the second chechen war
which began in the fall of 1999 it is
still ongoing to this day although very
much at a reduced level and what this
paper is really looking at is how the
insurgents have responded to Russian
aggression against villages and
pro-russian chechen with soldiers who
have come from the insurgency to side
with the Russians against their own
people how the insurgents respond to
them as well okay and what led you to
write this paper this is actually part
of a broader series of paper
that is being funded by the United
States Institute of Peace and the
Northern Caucasus as a whole it offers
hate to use of word a laboratory but a
very nice way of looking at a whole
series of these conflict processes as
they unfold the region which i think is
unfamiliar to many to many viewers
perhaps but it's one of the most varied
on earth in terms of ethnicity in terms
of geography it has everything from low
plains to vast hills
it has mono ethnic Republic's in it it
has very very diverse republics within
it most of them are Muslim but they have
very very different patterns of violence
across some are neighbouring each other
have no violence one for example
Dagestan is incredibly violent you'll
move over slightly Chechnya again
incredibly violent but totally different
patterns of violence you move over to a
third and farther west on the snow
violence and then it picks up as you
move farther west and and new patterns
of violence so the region as a whole
offers is a very interesting way of
looking into this and saying why are
these patterns occurring and I think we
don't understand these patterns
generally across little wars and so this
offers one way which is neatly compact
put together geographically the Russian
is the language across all of them
so they have a common heritage but yet
this unique diversity so we can look at
and begin to test and experiment and use
our theories to try and test and say
what is going on here
what can we shed light on not just these
conflicts but also broader patterns of
violence elsewhere ok and let's talk
about your methodology how did you
gather the data for your paper this
actually is we like to say as political
scientists of course that we have a
master plan and everything falls into
place perfectly this not so much
this was actually came through luck
believe it or not I was a graduate
student in Moscow and st. Petersburg
when the war first began and I was doing
interviews with policymakers and
military officials Chechnya was not on
my radar screen at this time and in fact
most people as it was not simply because
that the censorship regime around the
war was very very tight and he couldn't
get much information on it and I was
coming home one night on the Moscow
Metro I'm half asleep from an interview
and happened to notice that someone had
stuck a placard over one of the windows
saying that there was going to be an
anti Chechen war protest the following
night this is very hard for people to
organize this with Putin and we have to
remember at the time cracking down on
civil society cracking down on
outlets so someone has started
distributing leaflets within the metro
stations and so people who are on the
the trades could see and I said this
sounds like a good opportunity I think
I'll go and see and see what happens if
people protest and I subsequently did
that for the following four and a half
years on and off viewing these anti-war
activists and I got to know them and
their key means of getting information
out around the blockade was it hand out
a little broad sheet that had daily
records of abuses inflicted by Russian
soldiers and Biogen insurgents during
the war by day essentially and then they
would give out a weekly broad sheet and
the no one was interested the passerby
er would just but just leave it but I
was interested because this is said to
me that there were data that there were
people collecting at courageous people
collecting it and I wondered if I could
get my hands on that and I essentially
helped actually understand what's going
on on a day-to-day level by taking these
documents so a lot of the data came from
human rights groups they came from
activists they came from journalists who
are still working in the region mostly
Russian language sources and then from
that we just compiled it all into one
big data set and then began to ask the
questions Wow okay why is it important
to look at MSAD during wartime violence
so ethnicity to some is the holy grail
of explaining patterns of violence
almost everything reduces down to it and
many people you asked and say could you
explain Rwanda could you explain Bosnia
could you explain a rock today without
ethnicity and most people would say no a
rock looks like a sunni-shia Civil War
though or the Tutsi and Hutu in Rwanda
how could you explain it without that it
explains who is being killed when
they're being killed the actual location
if we look at intermixed populations is
typically the fault lines for the war
others however say ethnicity matters not
a bit because identity is the product of
the war not the cause of it so there's a
really interesting debate about whether
it's actually doing anything at all or
doing everything at once and the
position I take in this paper is that's
probably somewhere in the middle and
what we really want to do is be able to
test it because what I think what we can
do in explaining it is not just where
the mount's occurs and whom is
victimized but also that the violence
itself the responses to it are
conditional on the identity of the
perpetrator and this is something our
theories don't really talk about we just
assume violence is a violent act as a
violent act but in fact it matters whom
is inflicted in
and so ethnicity I think unlocks that
and if we can get our hands on figuring
out whom is doing what to whom we can
actually explain a lot more the dynamics
of the violence okay and let's talk a
little bit more about the conclusions
you reach in your paper absolutely the
main conclusion interestingly enough is
that the Chechen rebels who were once
rebels who have now sided with the
Russians are much more effective counter
insurgents and the Russians are
themselves why is that well they come
from the same communities basically the
Russians actually oftentimes will put
them back to where they were born or
where they were recruited from and they
know the people and so they know who the
insurgents are and if they can't find
the insurgents they know who the
families are so they know essentially
whom to threaten and who to actually go
into the villages and identify and say
you're an insurgent you're coming with
us
the Russians don't they typically don't
have the language skills most Russians
don't speak Chechen most Russian
soldiers are eighteen-year-old
conscripts they don't have much time in
there they're very poorly paid they
don't want to be there and so the
Russians when they come through
typically brutalize but brutalize on a
large scale and they don't actually know
who the insurgents are the Chechens when
they come through know whom to brutalize
essentially and so they come through and
they find the insurgents and they remove
them from the population and so over
time one of the main conclusions it as
the Russians sweep the villages they
come through and they do these
operations to pull the insurgents out
the violence goes up after the the
Russians leave when the Chechens of
comparable size and comparable level
brutality towards the population comes
through the violence drops dramatically
so we get a net reduction of about 40
percent subsequent levels of insurgents
once the Chechens are sweeping their own
people so that's one of the main
conclusions the second is that this is
an incredibly dangerous policy bgb
practicing because what you're
essentially doing is arming communities
within the community that you're trying
to control and setting them at odds
against one another and this has nothing
for the post-war stability so the
Russians have bought a measure of peace
right now by essentially turning the
Chechens against themselves once the
Russians withdrawal they've essentially
armed the Chechen communities into at
least four little groups each with
weapons each ready to scrap for the turf
once the Russians leave so short-term
this seems to be effective although very
brutal in the long term this may be
sowing
seeds for a future conflict and I think
this is actually a conclusion that
travels this is the same thing the
United States is trying to do in
Afghanistan today with the Afghan
militia is the same to the United States
did in Iraq for example with the Sons of
Iraq movement where a armed local
militia because they were better at
counterinsurgency than the incoming
incumbent the United States or in this
case the Russians and then it just
creates trouble down the road
absolutely I mean I think this is
something we don't actually know about
is what are the long-term implications
of this but my suggestion for Chechens
are probably not good right right what
was the most surprising thing you found
in doing research for this paper perhaps
the most surprising thing was that I
could actually do it when I started the
project many people said there will be
no data this is a heavy censorship
regime the Russians do not want you
there they do no one information to come
out and they control the television and
most of the print media so this is very
hard information but the human rights
groups and memorial is one of the big
human rights groups have found ways
around the censorship network ways to
get on the internet ways to actually
have email access into the they're
spotters on the ground in Chechnya
and we have much more information than
we ever thought possible and I think the
thing that's even most encouraging in
some ways and surprising is that now we
can go on to the web and download
hundreds of pages of testimony by
Russians who have been victim
excuse me by Chechens who have been
victimized in the appear in court of
human rights for example has collected
all this and there's hundreds of pages
of this online so more and more data
every day is becoming available and I
think down the road that scholars will
have even better understanding of what's
going on so I think the surprising and
encouraging how much we know about a
place that people don't want to
snowbelle in the first place and all
thanks to the internet and many in many
regards and being people being able to
post information that's amazing actually
absolutely yeah they've been very
creative at finding work around blogs in
some cases they've encrypted their
emails so that they can't be read by the
russian intelligence apparatus who was
monitoring these activities a lot of
courage and a lot of creativity and and
and they've done they've shown a light
on a very dark corner okay very
interesting thanks so much for being
here with us today and sharing some of
your work thank you very much for more
information about Professor Lyle and his
work please visit our website at Yale
edu backslash Macmillan report be sure
to join us
for another episode of the Macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at yeah
you